you have questions I sometimes have
answers Bears ready I'm ready are you
ready Robin Discord why do people Twitch
in the middle of their sleep and scare
the baby whoop out of me you go through
different stages of sleep and when
you're in your deepest stage of sleep
you actually turn off uh your
musculoskeletal movements that
neurological system shuts down but
sometimes when you're going in between
stages it doesn't fully shut down and
you're still in sleep and you're
dreaming so some of those movements that
actually do get through bear once did
that too and you kicked me I was upset
with him what actually causes the
sensation of an itch well this is a
complex process that's primarily
histamine driven there is a specific
type of nerve cell fiber known as a c
fiber these are sort of The receptors
that actually initiate the sensation of
an itch usually a response to like a
mechanical or chemical process it's an
inflammatory response it's a form of an
inflammatory response this chord Naomi
multifandom why are vaccines usually
administered in the shoulder well it's a
great muscle deltoid muscle a lot of
circulation it's quick it's easy you
don't have to get really fully undressed
in order to make that injection happen
back in the day we used to use the
gluteus maximus or the buttock now it's
a little bit invasive and it's easier to
just go in the shoulder and do the same
thing YouTube the house office why are
you a fluffy cinnamon roll I must
protect
first of all I ain't no cinnamon roll
Okay the reason I eat no cinnamon roll
is because while I am delicious I am
healthy
I'm like a doctor
since it's coming yeah but you don't
know what direction it's coming no
preparing you don't know what the word
is gonna get ready for something like
that what can cause a constant ringing
in someone's ears other than loud music
noise what can get rid of it this is
really interesting because tinnitus is a
constant ringing in the ears and it can
be a ringing could be a buzzing it's all
sorts of sounds that can happen and a
lot of times the reason why my patients
come in is as a result of serum and
impaction or earwax blockages another
thing that causes it is sensor neural
hearing loss you actually develop
hearing loss for one of many different
reasons and as a result of losing actual
hearing you start hearing ringing in
your ears which is manufactured by the
actual nerve that transmits the sound a
lot of people think it means you're
hearing something it actually could be a
form of hearing loss that's why it's
very important to always get it checked
out Discord Ariel a lot of medical shows
movies you see Med students shocked at
being exposed to cadavers for the first
time does this ever happen in real life
where seeing a dead person for the first
time a med student will get sick or
faint yeah it happens also the fumes of
the formaldehyde are pretty stenchy I
don't know if that's a word but I was
kind of in awe the first time that I saw
them but the scary part was when I was
studying for for an exam late Friday
night that was for an exam on Monday
being alone in a cadaver lab in the dark
hearing noises thunderstorm outside no
better Discord Jess Michio I always get
a runny nose because of spicy food what
is that about that is about capsaicin it
is a nutrient that is found in spicy
foods that actually bind to specific
receptors in your body giving you the
sensation of burning there's no actual
burning happening it's tricking your
body to think it's on fire and as a
result your body protects Itself by
trying to lubricate the area releasing
mucus Etc it's a great way to clear your
sinuses by the way I'm considering
buying a posture corrector do they
really work generally speaking here I
would say no I want you when you come in
with a poor posture is to figure out a
what's causing it and B to actually
allow your body to fix it or if it's bad
enough posture for an anatomical concern
refer you to an orthopedic specialist to
figure out why that's happening posture
corrector is almost end up doing more
harm than good in many cases where they
weaken your core muscles your stability
muscles and as a result making you more
likely to get injured there are certain
ones on the market for specific
conditions that may work but I would
generally try and stay away unless your
doctor absolutely recommends them
Discord Kristen G what up Discord for
those who don't know we have a private
Discord where we chat patreon members
only signed up down below what's the
best way to get electrolytes after a
hard workout without adding sugar
electrolytes are not added through sugar
electrolytes are essentially salts that
your body needs to function and the way
that you get these is by eating Foods or
beverages that contain those
electrolytes sodium doesn't taste great
after a workout but after a grueling one
it really does help you absorb the water
and stay more hydrated back in the day
they used to use pickle juice sure
tastes good too not bad I like it I like
pickles
is there a way for a civilian to test
and see what kind of nutrients their
body has a lot or a little of I'm always
confused about what to eat and would be
great to know if I'm eating too much or
too little of something currently
there's no such thing on the market yes
we can do specific blood tests to see if
you're low on certain vitamins or if
you're anemic and things like that but
generally we don't screen for these
things if you feel great and you have no
symptoms there's no point looking for
them because a lot of times if you feel
good and your lab value is a little bit
off we still decide not to treat the
value because the reality is we treat
the patient not the lab values why do
our stomachs growl usually because
they're angry no I'm kidding the reason
they growl is because of peristalsis the
muscles in the stomach actually try and
churn the food in order to be act as a
form of mechanical digestion because
remember there's multiple types of
digestion there's chemical mechanical
mechanical being chewing peristalsis the
stomach churning and that makes a
growling noise also remember when you're
dealing with foods and there's bacteria
inside our gut there's also gases
release that gas as it makes its way
through the the digestive system can
make those noises and then at the end of
the day we fart Lance McPhee YouTube how
often should you shower and wash your
hair I have this argument so often
because there are people who say you
have to shower every single day and she
wash your hair every single day and that
is in fact not reality the decision to
wash your hair should really be
individualized one a holistic one
meaning that yes if your hair is very
greasy or your scalp is itchy or there's
a lot of dandruff may be a good reason
to wash your hair yes if you come home
and you're smelly from the gym please
shower but otherwise like if you just
had a normal day it's not absolutely
mandatory that you shout and it's not
absolutely mandatory that you need to
use shampoo and depending on your hair
type also decides how often you should
be washing your hair goes with very fine
hair maybe every day every other day
those with more textured hair can go
several days without washing their hair
but know that the more often you wash
your hair the more that you actually
take off some of those important oils
off of your scalp you can actually cause
damage more irritation dry out your hair
etc etc when it comes to showering same
thing your skin doesn't like hot water
your skin doesn't like having soap all
over it all the time in fact your shower
should be really ideally short like
three or four minutes just focusing on
like you're growing your armpits that's
about it why do so many people set a
step gold count of 10K days there any
scientific reason for this
yeah the 10K thing doesn't really mean
much look however whatever way you
choose to get active it will be healthy
for you if you're increasing from 5K
steps to 7K steps amazing if you've been
working out one day a week and you've
gone to three days a week amazing I will
never be that rigid doctor that's like
see by your watch here you've averaged
999.9 steps
disappointed
it's time for me to cut you as a patient
is eating burn food bad for you actually
it is Neko muser you actually create all
these cancer-causing chemicals when you
eat burnt Foods so ideally you want to
stay away from chard as much as possible
in fact marinate marinating your Meats
help prevent some of those hydrocarbons
and other toxic nutrients from forming
they're not even nutrients chemicals
from forming actually eating greens with
your Meats helps decrease some of the
cancer-causing minerals as well keep
calling them different things nutrients
minerals they're chemicals seaweed ties
does banging one's head from the side
actually Shake water out from your ears
or is that something they do in cartoons
don't bang your head that's how
concussions happen just jump
and the gravity will do the trick
if someone gets stabbed in the stomach
will the stomach acid seep out into
their body and start dissolving their
organs uh yeah it's very problematic
when someone has a stomach injury like
it won't completely dissolve their
organs but it'll cause damage it'll
cause a peritonitis Hyper Shadow sniper
76 when you're performing chest
compressions you break the Ribs Right
couldn't that broken rib puncture an
organ below because you're putting so
much pressure on it you can but guess
what if you're performing chest
compressions that person's already dead
and you're trying to bring them back to
life so anything you can do to continue
their time by circulating the blood
that's already in the circulatory system
that has some oxygen left you're buying
them some extra added survival time
that's why you don't do chest
compressions on people who are alive
Tara Discord is there a way to suppress
my gag reflex I literally gag every time
I brush my teeth I had to Patient tell
me the exact same thing what I told them
is this is kind of a weird trick put his
thumb tuck his thumb underneath his fist
when he's brushing his teeth and for
some reason this worked very well for
him easy enough to try but if it's
happening quite often seeing your doctor
and figuring out if everything's okay in
your oral cavity is probably a smart
move Sam hours from three feet away you
said there's a much higher fiber content
eating a fruit itself as opposed to just
drinking the juice do I also lose a lot
of fiber in homemade smoothie because
the fruit is getting broken down by a
blender does the blender not break it
down enough to alter the fiber volume
good question you Sam and the answer is
yes the the beginning of that mechanical
digestion by your smoothie actually does
decrease some of that fiber content
because your body has to do less work
now thanks Dr Mike
I watch the office medical scenes and
reacted to them right here I bet you
didn't know that they did chest
compressions on the office CPR c-p-r as
always stay happy and healthy foreign
[Music]